"If you cross your eyes,
they'll stay that way."
Man, that's an oldie but a goodie.
"It's OK to go swimming
or take a shower in contact lenses."
All right, everybody does it.
But they really shouldn't.
"Styes are contagious."
No!
Not at all.
Styes are not contagious.
And you don't get them from pools.
And you don't get them
from rubbing your eyes.
Rupa Wong: Doorknobs.
Jenifer Bossert: Kissing others.
No, you don't get them
from any of those things.
Aloha, my name is Dr. Jenifer Bossert.
I am the optometrist at
the Honolulu Eye Clinic.
I've been in practice for 30 years,
and my specialty is contact lenses.
And aloha, everyone.
I am Dr. Rupa Wong.
I am a board-certified ophthalmologist.
I've been in private practice
here in Hawaii for 13 years
working alongside this
wonderful lady here.
I specialize in pediatric ophthalmology
and adult strabismus.
And today we are here to
debunk myths about vision.
We're going to start off with
debunking myths that we
used to think were true.
"Reading in the dark or while lying down
will damage your vision."
No, this is a myth.
It does not damage your vision.
And my oldest son reads
in the dark all the time.
My mother, obviously knows
I'm an ophthalmologist,
still comes to my house and tells me,
"Your son should not read in the dark."
Not true.
Because people need good
light to see better,
they assumed maybe that when
you're reading in the dark,
because it is usually more challenging,
maybe they thought that
was straining your eyes.
People confuse those issues
with damaging your eyes.
"Eating carrots will
improve your eyesight."
I have actually just studied
where the origin of this myth came from.
It's really interesting.
So, it was basically a
campaign during World War II
because the British air fighter pilots
had this radar technology
to be able to detect the German targets.
But they didn't want the Germans to know
that they had the radar technology,
so they just said that their air pilots
were eating a lot of carrots
and therefore had good night vision.
How fascinating!
See? I learned something today.
I love it!
Wong: Vitamin A is very
important for the metabolism
that's being performed in your retina.
Bossert: A, C, E, magnesium,
lutein, omega-3s,
those are the common ones
that we all consider important
for optimum eye health.
Zinc.
Wong: All of these vitamins can help halt
the progression of macular degeneration,
but in the studies it didn't demonstrate
any more effect for people like us,
that don't have any macular degeneration.
"Wearing someone else's
glasses will ruin your vision."
If a child, really younger than 13,
is wearing someone else's glasses,
it can ruin their vision
if it is completely off.
Because if it's promoting blurry vision,
that's going to inhibit the growth
of the connections between
the eyes and the brain.
So kids under 13, they
are in a special period
of their vision development
called the critical period.
So, absolutely, I never, ever recommend
that children wear anybody else's glasses.
But for adults, it's a little
bit of a different story.
Bossert: With adults, it
isn't going to harm your eyes,
but it can contribute to eye fatigue,
eye strain, headaches.
So, yes, we always encourage everybody
to get their annual checkups,
wear their own glasses,
and keep them updated.
"Sitting too close to the TV
is bad for your eyesight."
Typically a parent wants their child
to move back from the television,
and it's a total myth.
And it doesn't harm an
adult's eyes, either.
So, when I have a parent
ask me that in the exam,
I encourage them to bring them in
so that we can actually check their child
and just see if it's a
habit that the child has
or whether they actually have
an underlying nearsighted
process occurring.
If they're sitting too
close to the television,
then I'm concerned that maybe they've been
developing nearsightedness.
A young child doesn't know
that that's happening.
Just because your parents are nearsighted
does not mean 100% you're
going to be nearsighted.
Several studies have shown
that two hours a day
of sunlight is helpful
at preventing nearsightedness progression.
So I always tell my
patients to get outdoors,
but it's not so easy in other
parts of the country or world.
"If you cross your eyes,
they'll stay that way."
Man, that's an oldie
but a goodie, I think.
I remember my grandmother telling me.
We were out running around,
and kids all playing,
and my grandmother saying,
"Your eyes are going to stay that way!"
Of course, that is actually
my area of specialty, is crossed eyes.
That's what I do surgery for, to fix them.
And I can tell you, I've never
had to operate on anybody
who crossed their eyes in intentionally
and it got stuck that way.
So that's a complete myth.
Some people are born with it.
We call that congenital esotropia.
Typically, if you're born with it,
you're born with crossed eyes.
Sometimes people develop
it because the eye is blind
for whatever reason, a separate reason.
So if they're young, then the eye
tends to cross in with the blind eye.
If they're older and they
sustain some kind of trauma
or injury to the eye to
cause it to become blind,
then the eye wanders out.
'Cause I've seen so many patients
that have come from other eye doctors
who have been told for years,
No. 1, "Your insurance doesn't cover it."
No. 2, "You're too old for this surgery."
I've operated on a 95-year-old.
"Squinting is bad for your eyes."
We do know that when you squint,
you tend to be able to
see a little bit better
when you're nearsighted.
Something called the pinhole effect.
So that could be how
that myth got started.
A parent might see their child squinting
and then think that it was the squinting
that actually caused the nearsightedness,
but it was the opposite.
The nearsightedness caused the squinting.
"You will become dependent on your glasses
if you wear them too much."
As someone who now has started
to need reading glasses,
it is really hard to
not believe this myth.
I, when I take my reading glasses off,
I swear I could see the iPhone way better.
Bossert: It's not that the
glasses made your vision worse,
it's just that your
brain got used to having
good, sharp vision when you put them on.
So then when you take them off,
your brain's like,
"No! I want them back again!
I like seeing clearly!"
"You can't wear your contacts
if you have astigmatism."
This is definitely not true.
I still hear that in this day and age,
despite media campaigns,
despite information dissemination.
People still believe that
if they have astigmatism,
they won't be able to wear contact lenses.
Or that they're going to have
to be hard contact lenses.
Yes. Because 30 years ago, it was true,
that really the only
way that you could mask
that astigmatism was to take a hard lens
and put it on the eye.
But now, daily disposables, I can correct
2.75 units of astigmatism,
which is a lot.
And in a reusable contact lens,
I can go up to 5.75.
I even have a brand-new option
that if you are over 40
and need reading glasses,
if you have astigmatism,
you can even wear a bifocal contact lens
that corrects for astigmatism now.
But they are more difficult to fit
because they interact with the eyelid,
the shape of the eye.
So sometimes we'll have to go through
two or three lens designs
to find the best one for the patient.
But it's pretty rare that
we can't find something
in this day and age.
Wong: Now we're gonna talk about
myths we hear all the time.
"Staring at a screen all day
will make your eyesight worse."
Well,
the jury's still a little
bit out on this one.
Yes, anecdotally, we perceive that people
that spend longer hours on a screen
are the ones that are more
likely to end up nearsighted.
But studies don't prove that.
And particularly with COVID,
with COVID and homeschooling,
online schooling,
we've seen a huge increase
in parents asking us,
"Do I need to get my kid blue blockers?"
Well, the answer is no.
There was a small study
that came out and said that,
yes, it could help decrease fatigue.
But, like any study, we need
to take those small studies
and turn them into large studies
to really truly get facts and figures
that hold out for the larger population.
So when they redid the
study, it came out 50-50.
It just really wasn't proven
to be statistically significant.
Wong: And that's why we always
recommend the 20-20-20 rule.
People need to take breaks
every 20 minutes for 20 seconds
where they look at something 20 feet away.
"Only people with bad
eyesight need eye exams."
That is definitely a myth.
There's all sorts of conditions
that still you have --
Retinal holes, retinal
tears, retinal detachments.
That's another thing,
where people always think,
mistakenly, that they've had LASIK
and as if LASIK has
corrected their eyeballs.
And it hasn't. It's just
made their vision better.
But they still have the
pathology, the retinal issues,
that they still require exams once a year.
Bossert: People think
that they're going to
the eye doctor for their vision.
Eye doctors would tell
you that you're going
to the eye doctor for your eye health.
Because if you don't
maintain the eye health,
then you're not going to be able
to maintain good eye vision
for the 100 years that
you're present on this earth.
"You won't get glaucoma if
you have perfect vision."
Glaucoma is something that's asymptomatic.
So you can have perfect 20-20 vision
and have the absolute
worst end-stage glaucoma.
Glaucoma is typically high
pressure inside the eye,
which causes damage to the
optic nerve of the eye.
Bossert: And in the beginning,
there are no signs whatsoever.
So really the only way
that we can detect glaucoma
is to come in for your
annual eye examination.
And there are a series of tests that we do
in the examination itself
that allow us to screen for glaucoma.
So, when you catch glaucoma early,
then we can start treatments earlier.
And we can't reverse any vision loss
or any optic-nerve damage,
but we can prevent future
damage from happening,
or at least slow that progression down.
So, we start with eyedrops.
We can even do laser treatments,
which help with that drainage system
and bring the fluid down.
And then if we need to,
we escalate to glaucoma surgeries.
Bossert: Myths from the internet.
Let's do those next.
"It's OK to go swimming
or take a shower in contact lenses."
All right, everybody does it.
But they really shouldn't.
You can really develop blinding infections
from tap water and from
water that's in hot tubs.
Bossert: 'Cause no
matter what body of water
we're talking about,
they all have some bacteria
in them, even tap water.
Which, that bacteria that bothers our eyes
doesn't bother our stomach,
yet you don't want to have it in the eye.
Yes, do we all wash our
face and we get water in?
We do.
But the critical thing is that
this particular bug, called pseudomonas,
is small enough that it can embed itself
in the pores, in the
matrix of the contact lens.
And then it gets on your
eye, and it sits there,
and it sits there, and it sits there,
for all those hours that you have it on.
And that's when the risk becomes high.
'Cause then you reach up and you rub,
you disturb the top layer
of cells on the eye.
Now there's a little
window for that bacteria
to walk right into the eye.
And unfortunately with pseudomonas,
we don't have good treatment modalities.
It's very resistant to the antibiotics
that we have available to us.
"Stress causes eye floaters."
No.
Age causes eye floaters.
And trauma.
A floater is just, it's
a vitreous detachment.
And I tell my patients the
vitreous is like Jell-O.
When you get older, it starts to liquefy,
and you get pockets, and dries up.
And that's what causes separates
from the inner lining, from the retina.
And that then floats all
around in your field of vision.
But it's actually inside your eye.
People think it's a cockroach,
they think it's an ant.
They try to swat it away.
It's not any of those things,
but it's an actual change
in the anatomy of your eye.
It's not caused by stress.
"LASIK surgery is not safe."
LASIK surgery is definitely safe.
At this point, LASIK
surgery's been around ...
35 years now?
Yes. If you were to do a Google search
that pulled up some of
those early results,
there were definitely instances
where there were
cases of blindness.
A lot of that was changed
by further advancements in the technology,
different ways to make the flap.
So now, in this day and age,
I would say that LASIK
surgery is perfectly safe.
That said, there is no
surgery for any body part
that doesn't come with
a risk of complications.
Like, any body part.
Wong: Yeah, totally.
You want the doctor
that's doing the procedure
on a weekly basis.
You don't want the
doctor that's doing this
once every three or four months.
Wong: "Styes are contagious."
Bossert: No.
Wong: Not at all.
Styes are not contagious.
And you don't get them
from pools, public pools.
Bossert: And you don't get
them from rubbing your eyes.
Wong: Doorknobs.
Bossert: Kissing others.
No, you don't get them
from any of those things.
Just like some people
can have more oily skin
or more dry skin.
I describe it kind of like a pimple.
Bossert: The contents in the oil gland
can be different consistencies.
So if you tend to have
that heavier, thicker oil
inside the gland itself,
then you can be more
prone to getting them.
Wong: And usually what
we want to do is heat.
A lot of heat is going to help it drain.
Pink eye is contagious.
What most people think of as pink eye
is viral conjunctivitis.
Sometimes it can be
bacterial conjunctivitis.
Viral conjunctivitis is
really, really contagious.
That you do get from doorknobs
and the surface of objects.
Is that something people think?
Producer: Yeah.
Not true.
What I hope people take
away from this video
is that they get their annual eye exams,
they don't equal good
vision with eye health,
that they take their contact lenses out
when they sleep and they shower,
and that they follow the 20-20-20 rule.